لكن هذه كما تقول
لحظة مختلفة وأه رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو
قال أنك لا تعرف فقط
الانتقام ومحاسبة حماس
ولكن التغيير الذي تعرفه
قطع الرأس بالكامل لتدمير حماس هذه هي
الكلمات التي نسمعها أم و  إلى
وأفترض إزالة
قدرتهم العسكرية والسياسية داخل غزة، وهذا أيضًا
تغيير
لأنك تركتهم هناك في المواجهات السابقة
وأخبرني الآن ما هو
الهدف النهائي فيما يتعلق
بهم، انظر إلى أن إسرائيل قد حشدت بالفعل
عدة مئات الآلاف من
جندي احتياط منتشر في جميع أنحاء المنطقة حتى
لو اتسع نطاق الصراع. لا أريد
ذلك. إسرائيل لا تحتاج إليه ولا
أوصي بذلك، لكن من
المحتمل جدًا أن يحدث ذلك حتى لو وجدت أنفسنا
نقاتل ضد هاتين الجبهتين، إسرائيل
ليست كذلك.  تحت أي تهديد وجودي
ستنتصر إسرائيل، نعرف كيف نتحد
ونعرف كيف نقاتل وسننتصر،
أقولها من أجل تهدئة كل هذا القلق الذي
حدث لإسرائيل، إسرائيل ستفوز
بهذا الاختبار أيضًا، لكن كما ذكرت
سابقًا قد تفوز.  قد يستغرق الأمر بعض الوقت، قد يكون هناك
صعود وهبوط، قد يكون هذا شيئًا
تعرفه عندما تنظر إلى
حجم الحدث وحتى
إذا تمكنت من إلقاء نظرة على
الصور الرسومية، فهذا أمر صادم للغاية، نعم لقد فقدنا عددًا
أكبر من الأشخاص مقارنة بالمجمل  حرب الأيام الستة
أو في الانتفاضة بأكملها، على مدى ثلاث
سنوات من الانتفاضة في يوم واحد، لم
يحدث ذلك مطلقًا في إسرائيل، يحاول الناس
مقارنتها بأحداث 11 سبتمبر، كما تعلمون، 11 سبتمبر كان
استخدام طائرة مدنية،
وكان
صاروخ كروز أمرًا جديدًا
كان الجدار ومهاجمة المستوطنات الإسرائيلية
أمرًا مرتفعًا جدًا في قائمة خيارات
كاماس وقد فشلنا في القيام بذلك
ودفعنا ثمنًا باهظًا الآن هناك حاجة
ليس فقط للانتقام في الشرق
الأوسط، عليك فقط أه  أعد استئناف
حالة الردع من أجل التأكد من
أنك ستؤخر ذلك، أفهم ذلك
لذا فأنت بحاجة إلى
إنشاء الردع مرة أخرى أريد أن أسألك
شيئًا عن العدو عدوك
وهو حماس أم الجيش حماس التي
أعلنت نفسها عسكرية
وقال القائد محمد اللدي في رسالة مسجلة إن
العدو أي إسرائيل ستفهم
أن زمن هياجهم دون
محاسبة قد انتهى كيف
تردون على
أنكم تعرفون الـ K إذا كان لا بد لي من
مقارنتهم بأي منظمة
عرفناها في المنطقة  في الماضي، كان الأمر كما لو كان هناك
بعض منهم حصلوا على
مستوى أفضل من الأداء
عما كانوا عليه في الماضي، كما أدى ذلك إلى رفع
السعر وجعل الهجوم ناجحًا بما
يتجاوز كل إخفاقاتنا
وعلينا أن نأخذهم على محمل الجد  لقد
فاجأنا بنجاحهم ولكنهم
في الأساس أعداء لدودون على
عكس الأعداء الآخرين، لقد قاتلنا
بشدة مع الأردنيين مع
المصريين في النهاية يمكننا صنع السلام
معهم، لا توجد طريقة لصنع السلام
مع حماس لذا يجب أن يكونوا بطريقة ما.
مشلولة من القدرة
على العودة مرة أخرى كقوة مقاتلة
ضد إسرائيل وهذا سيتطلب الكثير
من العمل والكثير من الجهد والكثير من
التضحيات وآمل ألا يكون هناك الكثير من الوقت والوفيات
العالية جدًا، فكيف كان الأمر عندما
تنظر إليه و  أعلم أنك قلت ذلك، لقد
كان هذا أسوأ يوم في
تاريخنا وفشلًا كبيرًا
كما كان الجميع يتحدثون
عنه، لقد قلته للتو عن
الاستخبارات وعلى طول الطريق
السياسي أه  الطيف السياسي أه لقد
تحدثت مع مدير الموساد السابق
افرايم هاليفي الذي قال لي بالأمس
النظام تعرض
لصدمة زلزالية جدا جدا لذا فإن المشاعر داخل
بلدكم هي أيضا في حالة
صدمة رهيبة ومثل الجميع يتساءلون كيف
سيحدث هذا كيف محمد
يفعل DV وألويته هذا كيف
بدونك، كما تعلم، لقد كبرنا معتقدين
أن لديك مثل قوة عظمى هناك في
إسرائيل سياسيًا وعسكريًا واستخباراتيًا،
لا، إنها إسرائيل تظل قوة
عظمى مقارنة بحماس ولكن هذا
صحيح، إنها حقيقة واقعة  إذا
تم تدريب الشباب
بشكل منهجي، بل إنهم
يتحسنون من خلال
الاحتكاك المستمر معنا لأنه
عادةً ما يبقى الأفضل منهم
ويصعدون إلى أعلى، لقد تعلموا دروسهم ومن
الواضح أنهم تحسنوا، علينا أن
نأخذ قدراتهم لتكون
أعلى مما  لقد افترضنا حتى بضعة
أيام مضت أننا سنفعل ذلك، ولكن بعد أن
قلنا إنها في الأساس تظل
منظمة قاتلة حتى لو
كان الإرهابيون الأفراد
مدربين بشكل أفضل أو مجهزين بشكل أفضل وعلينا أن
نتعامل معهم، لا يمكن لأي
دولة متحضرة حديثة أن يكون لديها مثل هذا
جار يبدأ وينفذ مثل هذه
العملية، لا يمكننا تحمل حدوثها
مرة أخرى إذا كنت أهتم بشيء واحد هو
المستوى الأعلى لقيادتنا،
مجلس الوزراء الداخلي داخل حكومة H، فهو
الآن ضعيف نسبيًا لدينا هناك
وزير الدفاع ووزير آخر
كان أه سكرتيرًا أو كان رئيسًا
للخدمة السرية ونيتان نفسه هذا
مزيج ضعيف فريق ضعيف لقيادة
مثل هذه الأزمة وأعتقد أنه
يجب أن يكون هناك تغيير في مجلس الوزراء
ربما من خلال
حكومة الوحدة الطارئة أه ولكن هذا
ح أكثر
يجب جلب المزيد من الأشخاص الجادين إلى
مجلس الوزراء من أجل قيادة الأزمة، غرفة الطوارئ
بهدوء وهدوء وأنا
أطلب دائمًا التدخل في القضايا الإستراتيجية
خاصة أن غليان الدم ليس
وصفة جيدة لاتخاذ
قرار استراتيجي ناجح، هل يمكنني أن أسألك واحدًا؟
السؤال الأخير لأن هذا قد طرح
عدة مرات أنه كان لديكم
اشتباكات ضد غزة وضد
حماس، كما يتم مهاجمة المدنيين أيضًا
سواء قلت أنك تنوي ذلك أم لا،
هناك بعض أه حسب
أه الوزارة هناك في غزة ما يقرب من
800  قُتل شخص بما في ذلك أكثر من
100 طفل،
وأصيب 4000 شخص، وقد
أعلنت حكومتك أن وزير دفاعك قد أعلن أن غزة تحت الحصار، وهو ما
تقول الأمم المتحدة إنه غير قانوني في الواقع بموجب
القانون الدولي، حيث يتوقف وقف المياه والغذاء
والوقود والكهرباء، وكم من الوقت
ستستمر
حكومتك في ذلك؟  إلى متى سيستمر الأمر مرة واحدة
كما تعلمون سيحدث سيكون هناك
انتقادات للمذبحة التي نراها أيضا
داخل غزة
أه سنحاول أن نوضح أننا نعلن
مقدما لكل من يعلم أن في
بنايته أي نشاط
للكماس يجب أن  من أجل حماية
نفسه بمغادرة المكان نحاول
تمرير هذا النوع من التحذير، لا نفعل،
لا نجلس على نفس المستوى، نحن
بلد متحضر، لن نذهب إلى
هناك أضرار جانبية معينة لكل
دولة تعمل في ظل مثل هذا
المواقف ونعرفها ولكن هذا هو
الفرق الكامل الذي نقوم به وهو
نتيجة حتمية إلى حد ما للاضطرار إلى
مهاجمتهم عندما
نشروا أنفسهم عمداً بين
المواطنين أثناء دخولهم إلى كيم
ومستوطنة أخرى ومدينتين
عمداً من أجل المذبحة
والنفوذ بشكل أساسي  البشر كبار السن
بعضهم نعم